if you beat charlie today and you beat
code miko
you go to the uh the winner's bracket
then you play i don't know whoa
oh if i had known that i would have did
what i did last time and
learned his first 10 moves you can't
learn my moves i'm unpredictable jimmy
i literally would have went through it
and watched every game of chess you've
ever played
you'd have to set aside a whole year to
watch my games
all right release your last 100 darn it
okay all right well regardless
we'll see how it goes
oh i didn't even realize they started
they started and charlie busts out the
uh the dutch
the dutch defense by charlie and wait a
second has he
removed his face this doesn't work
yes he has yes he has
wha uh-huh i'm free moving baby
those squares are moved with red have
you noticed
jimmy beast is making actual moves have
you seen
wow he lets
five moves after pushing f5 the rest of
the kingside development was pre-moved
if if mr beast had some pre-move
training and he noticed what charlie was
doing he could have tried to take
advantage of the pre-moves
yes that well he yeah that wow that was
some savage stuff that would have been
really tragic can you imagine if charlie
just got caught with something
my god um but charlie plays
h4 uh sorry mr beast has played h4 i
love it i love it especially if he gets
h5 and then
sacrifices that's never [ __ ] it's like
naradinsky's own playing style but being
played against charlie
did he just say he doesn't have a plan
wait he just he just took
instantly what
do this checkmated very soon if he
continues this way
charlie danger danger hey
is the best move knight takes h7 not
necessarily and then bishop h5 pawn h5
and like queen h5 like what is the best
move here for white i feel like the best
move is f4 or something ridiculous like
just daniel showed me something like
this and i forgot how it goes
well it's basically just actually a
little sack yep
but in this case bishop takes he he
knows it he remembers but
not super precisely but he he's got it
i wonder if mr beast will realize that
as tempting as it is to capture the
knight
on h5 oh well he goes for it the knight
on g5 is hanging that's the only
issue with this attack wow look at
charlie he's he doesn't even take back
that's beautiful
observation there if charlie takes that
knight the game's going to end a lot
faster
because in my prediction because the
attack is nerfed
a little bit e4
realizing that that creates a discovered
attack and he feels good about it mr b
is feeling good about the discovered
attack
it could have been a brilliant move if
it wasn't for this
this capture or oh actually wait uh
bishop f3 traps the queen
charlie two blunder charlie also
blundered
yeah wasn't the best but queen takes g2
was not the right
reaction yeah actually i don't know what
the right way probably f4
just shutting the door on the bishop but
it was really complex i thought queen
takes g2
for the first sight at first
oh my god
oh i hope he doesn't see it
uh oh man see charlie's problem
oh my god i just saw it oh my queen can
be
my queen can be trapped i'd be
lined a little too hard
he's right and trying to play he's very
shitty spot if he sees it i wonder if he
spots the opportunity that queen
he's now trapped mr b is the underdog in
this match
that's huge going for it my queen is now
trapped wow
yeah that's amazing uh now charlie's
gotta really slow down
or actually he might speed up even more
because he sees beast got a minute and
40. this is not a position
a 700 rated player wants to play with a
minute and 40 on the clock
oh my gosh charlie had to get rid of the
knight he is not fighting on equal
footing like
he has to get his pieces out that is the
issue i know we're looking at this from
beast perspective so all beast needs to
do is play
boop boop and get something going maybe
boop sneak in here take on d4 now since
the knight has moved away from the
protection of the d4 pro and it's it's
free stuff yes he plays king b1 so again
it's charlie's moment he's got to get
the rest of the pieces out oh my god
he is charlie's gone off the deep end
but frankly jimmy's got 15
seconds i hope he'll turn that flag
c2 and now he hung the house oh it's
done
mate it's not just hanging the rook it's
mate
oh can we cut the truck gotcha can we
get the
close call pikachu no gifted subs
oh okay well that was
far less dramatic that was i mean okay
all right
fine we get e4 i wonder if he's gonna
play the same opening
uh that we did last time okay so this
time he just goes for e5 the problem
with this
and not playing what he played against
ludwig
is the fact that charlie is
prepared with the vienna and this could
be a short game
uh charlie got the vienna from uh
i don't know some guy but whoa f5
f5 this is an anti-vienna
gambit if we want to refer to it that
way
uh well charlie's just going to take
right otherwise so many vienna lines
and i have never seen this ever
in my life okay the reason why d4 is
strong i was just gonna add
that he still has queen h5 and mr beast
realized that the pawn on e5 was hanging
so he's guarding it now with the knight
good thinking but it doesn't solve the
bigger issue which existed
prior to d4 yeah queen h5 is still
winning of course even de5 95 is totally
winning for white just
and he's played it i think now the best
move for black is d4
using that open space hitting the knight
removing your pawn out of danger and
only then taking back and
i don't know i don't know maybe beast
will take on f5 maybe e5
what's he gonna do i wonder which
capture will he go for if he takes any
of those pawns
bishop takes f5 would be the best option
out of the captures because that
prevents queen h5 but d4
look at you lovey you worked with the mr
beast for
an hour and now he's thinking like you
know by the way
chad i should say d4 is still losing
because of queen h5
but we're just pretending that that will
never get played so
if you add the little exception that
queen h5 cannot get played
because clearly no one's going to play
it or concerned about it
yeah blind spot charlie didn't see it
when it was possible straight away
yeah and then he had a second chance he
didn't see it now this is his third
chance
but the more the longer it's there on
the board
the more likely that he still will not
spot it it is a blind spot he's not
looking at that queen check
we could go
it really is not a nice one uh daniel
that
takes him so much time jimmy's got me
[ __ ] flustered i'll tell you what no
he doesn't charlie no he doesn't you got
yourself flustered jeez i'm
sure okay i've played like a thousand
three minute games over the last three
months and i've done
vienna and almost all of them i've never
seen someone push this f
pawn that's for a reason charlie for a
reason
usually it's either here a knight a
knight sometimes even a bishop
but i've never seen that for a reason
okay
all right anyway yeah it's not that he
uh
that he messed up well beast the thing
is beast also
just went all in and
yeah knight takes knight here
and that's yeah beast beast i told him i
was like you go to war sometimes without
developing all the pieces
and this is you know that's the thing
chess is a very
unforgiving game uh it's
your bad habits catch up to you
especially if you don't actively try to
like
improve them and anna anna having said
that if
knight d4 c5 i was gonna say there's
it's not that simple to counter this
charlie is up a piece but in order to
keep the piece he has to find
bishop d2 best move charlie's charlie's
definitely sharp
yeah charlie's just got to keep focused
here it can be really difficult to play
people who have five seconds
because you just it's like non-stop and
boom like right now rook c6 best move
take the pawn with check take
he misses it attacks the rook b's got to
see the rook does under attack
three two one one beast oh back to that
square oh he took it this time now he
takes it
i think that might be it i think that
might be it now beast is still firing
off moves
oh he's starting c4 yep
charlie can take yeah and now the rook's
getting out of there he's kicking the
rook out
0.9 seconds when mr beast made his final
move g6
clean clean clean rookie 7 rookie 7 is
gonna happen now
oh king c7 take the okay that's just and
there it is
beast resigns the game and charlie
an emphatic game fashion oh
basically prime fire and resub icaku
go go dad uh
but anyways regardless uh ggs you got
the best of me
um and what what'd you think of the game
i thought it was good man when you
trapped my queen i was like yep
jimmy saw it yeah that was not an easy
move to spot
there was a move uh deep in the second
game where i actually
could put my rook in front of one of
your pawns and i didn't see it yeah
i just yeah i just looked at that
i was so preoccupied with moving my
knight i didn't even look at my pawn
because my gut told me too i was like i
guarantee you he doesn't see it i was
like
there's just something about how weird
this board is he's gonna be so focused
over here
i was like i'm gonna get away with this
and i did yeah
but not the second time the second time
uh second time i got it
charlie was like question for you
because you know you gotta you got
obviously the prophet
uh and uh he's watching he's watching
your games you ever like
hear his voice in your head i know we
did a lesson or two but it's not the
same you got a full-time coach seriously
you ever hear his voice like what he's
gonna say to you when he's done
your games are done jesus yeah
absolutely it's
i can already hear it a hundred percent
the ravings of a
mad man the pre moves i know he did not
enjoy
and then uh in the second game when you
pushed that f-pawn i'd never seen it
before
i i played so many vienna games but i've
never seen the f-pawn push so i didn't
know how to react at all
and i missed a huge sequence if i went
over to the h file and i know he was
screaming he probably
threw his coffee cup on the ground and
just flipped over his table
does it feel like like like you're a
chess kid and he's a chess parent a
little bit like you come out of the
tournament room and you're like i won
and he's like you missed seven moves and
yeah that's absolutely how that feels it
feels like he's the strictest chess
parent ever
yeah i i enjoyed pog champs
was so much more fun than i thought it
would be um i i assume this is your
second one because i saw that clip on
youtube where you checkmated hqc or
whatever
um yeah we don't even remember his name
it was so brutal
and so now that i've experienced it next
time i'm in one i'm definitely gonna
train a lot like this was a lot of fun
uh you're not done oh wait yeah please
don't say goodbye no no no you're yeah
you're not done you got you got a game
in like a day or two against code mika
all right but now i'm like doomed to
lose like there's no way i win no
i think you've got a great chance
against that's the crazy thing
but that's like the petty game like it's
like you know what i'm gonna do
the bottom of the bottom listen jimmy
draw some inspiration you got a guy here
who last time he played in this event
was around the same strength you are now
right and then charlie worse yeah
okay i didn't say that you said that but
you went to the consolation bracket
and then you won it
[Music]
you